how do you stay excited in your career
I'm gonna answer that question in
today's episode of lunch and earn so
Risa got asked a question for one of my
youtube followers love you guys Aquila's
who wrote in to say hi evan i'm a
venezuelan recently graduated engineer
and I really love your videos
thanks man why do people say you start a
career with enthusiasm and a few years
later they're not as excited as they
were before I want to stay naive and
happy with my job luck I'm right now
actually don't care a lot about money
right now I just want to do important
things and learn what's wrong does this
happen only in a difficult country like
mine or this happens everywhere the sad
part is this happens everywhere because
quite often people get stuck and I rot
doing the same routine over and over and
over and over and over again so I'm
gonna share three ways to break out of
it and help ensure that you stay excited
in your career number one is follow your
curiosity I think when people are
younger they're really excited they're
really interested in learning new things
you're starting your career as an
engineer you've got nothing but dreams
and bright spots ahead of you and I
think as people get older especially
maybe not so much the entrepreneurs as
much as the people get stuck on the
corporate path they start to lose their
curiosity they start to lose their sense
of wonder because they're being told
what they can do and what they can't do
and what they want to explore something
or new option you've got a boss above
you saying no you can't do this and so I
think as much as possible you want to
try to keep that childlike sense of
wonder and curiosity and if you have an
idea if you're curious about something
go ahead and try it and try to keep that
throughout your entire life because if
you look at the people who are the most
successful in any field you look at the
people who are at the top they're
constantly being curious about how to
improve things about how to make life
better about how to make their industry
better and so I encourage you to try to
not lose that number two is surround
yourself with people younger than you
this is my sister Stephanie there's a
tremendous amount of energy creativity
ideas enthusiasm that younger people
have and if I was especially on the
corporate path I would try as much as
possible to surround myself with some
older people to get the mentor
ship and knowledge and learning and
understanding but the younger people to
get the energy and creativity and ideas
and and then they're saying the new
trends that are happening how that may
be able to help my career blossom
number three is explore other interests
if all you're doing is your business in
your career you're gonna find you get
stuck in the routine and you get bored
and a great way to break out of it is to
do other things that make you come alive
as well so whether that's baseball go
Jays go salsa dancing learning how to
play guitar picking up the skateboard
whatever it is something that you are
genuinely excited about go and try it
because in exploring a different world
you'll be able to take lessons from that
to then bring to your career and think
about things in a new way that other
people aren't thank you guys so much for
watching I would love to know your
thoughts on how you stay excited in your
business and in your career leave a
comment below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching you need to believe and I'll
see you soon